this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [ __ ] it's
monday the 19th of september the joint
is brought to you by draftkings listen
grab your nuts and salute the flag
football is back tuck suckers get on the
action at draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl they got big plays and even bigger
wins and they got an incredible offer
new customers just better fit on any nfl
team to win and you get 203 bets but
wait there's a lot more they stepped up
that same game paul a's for every leg
that you add you can boost your winnings
up to 100 percent i'm talking about a
hundred percent on same game police with
bigger payouts than ever why bet
football anywhere else draftking is an
official sports betting part of the nfl
is [ __ ] rocking so far this season
listen the prop bets are on fire so do
me a favor download the draftking
sportsbook app now use promo code joey
to get 203 bets if your team wins when
you place a bet on five dollars on any
football team that's code joey
only at draftkings sportsbook the
official
sports betting partner the nfl minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details now do me a
favor download the draftkings app and
let's make some [ __ ] cash
hey how you doing
come on
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's monday the 19th
welcome to another fun fill week on the
[ __ ] joint the guest is the one
and only
the master of disaster the flying
[ __ ] jew
uh we had a great time i'm still [ __ ]
recovering from last night guys i honest
to god i had to recover big man that was
a great night last night yes it was uh
if you guys got tickets to come to this
show any of the shows it's a
it was a real [ __ ] blast and it i
mean the whole night was phenomenal
just going into new york city
was
just [ __ ] the energy
there was so many [ __ ] people in that
city last night i've been going to that
city since the [ __ ] 60s
and what i saw last night i mean it was
the the opening night of general
defeat the feast of san gennaro i think
on thursday night and i think uh what
was what's her name was that the garden
schumer
really oh really i think either that or
a boston garden but there were a lot of
[ __ ] people in new york last night
out nobody gave a [ __ ] about covet
covert is officially over guys let me
tell you something it's so funny
yeah they're trying to [ __ ] they're
revving you up with that [ __ ] vaccine
that they only tried on eight mice
i'm [ __ ] human and they're gearing up
to [ __ ] shoot you to death
nobody cares about [ __ ] colvin it
does it doesn't even they keep selling
this [ __ ] backseat the booster [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] you nobody's even in the mood to
hear cover last night there were maybe
five dumb [ __ ] walking around
new york with a mask on let me tell you
there was so many people the mask
wouldn't work last night like there was
so many [ __ ] germs out the masks were
not gonna work
but it was well it took us
20 minutes just to get off our [ __ ]
block
like we went through ten lights and
moved like an inch that's how packed the
[ __ ] city was last night and the sony
theater [ __ ] beautiful
nice and rustic they got good food
the staff was great very nice very
[ __ ] nice
i want to give a shout out to laughing
gas for [ __ ]
showing up throwing away some [ __ ]
weed to the people people were [ __ ]
happy last night a lot of puerto ricans
last night a lot of spanish people i
love you [ __ ]
but yeah it was uh it was stu finer
knocking the mic off to stand this [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
smoking there was so much there had to
be 10 pounds of weed back there
yeah oh i walked in
i didn't even get to really go in the
green room because we got there late and
i just but i ran in at the end and i was
like oh it smells like it's joey's here
oh
there were mushrooms there were [ __ ]
chocolate covered mushrooms that the
chick was giving out i ain't through
that yeah jesus
oh it was [ __ ] superb but i gotta be
honest with you guys
let me tell you something
i was not nervous
at all like it didn't weigh on me all
week
it was like i was just going to do a set
it felt good it was great to be in new
york city the energy
the energy in new york is [ __ ]
world-class
it really [ __ ] is that's
the la don't have that you know you know
there's a lot of great cities in this
country but the energy in new york when
it's on i mean we saw mr softy
selling ice cream at 11 [ __ ] o'clock
i'm like who the [ __ ] is eating mr softy
and there were a [ __ ] line of people
out there it was just superb man
new york city when new york city's on
it's [ __ ] on jack when new york city
is on last night could have been at
eight in the morning night for us if we
really
it could have been scary because we
could have stayed at the sony theater
for like an hour or two and then gone to
eat and my plan was to go to wohop
and get chinese food in chinatown oh
but it closes at 10.
they used to be open 24 [ __ ] hours
so the city has changed a lot guys i've
been in the city five times before last
night and i never saw it like that
never
but it was just it felt so [ __ ] cool
like just to hey like just to do
stand-up in new york i was thinking when
i got back to the hotel last night i was
thinking about like the literally the
first night i met you
was at the old haha
on lancashire
and you were closing that show out with
like
seven
alcoholics
and like a homeless person in the heart
like it was like they were old couches
it was cra it was not the glitz and
glamour of broadway
and [ __ ]
what like what ten years
later that it was just so cool it was
just like there's really there's no
other way to describe it that it was
just an awesome
from every point of view it was an
awesome night and i got to tell you
something there was 10 big comedy shows
going on in the city
i walked by a couple that they were like
out there comedy center yeah yeah those
guys were there
guys there were 10 huge comedy shows in
the city last night
you know i don't know how many bands
played
those bands on in time square playing
right on the road
[ __ ] energy was tremendous guys you
know
i don't know last night did not feel
like a coveted night
last night
what i saw the people walking around
nobody was worried about colby nobody
gave a [ __ ]
if you showed up with a covert gun and
sprayed it they wouldn't have given a
[ __ ] last night they would have said
[ __ ] this well to have a [ __ ]
tremendous time you know
it's just weird when you don't do stand
up for a long like i didn't yep
i didn't know what to think when i got
back here i really didn't guys i was
confused i was going through a bunch of
[ __ ] and i just did not want to be
caught up in people throwing bottles and
stuff i was hearing [ __ ]
and then over time i said i got to get
my life together i got to do something i
got something nobody's going to hire me
to work
like nobody's not costco nobody's going
to get me
so i was like god damn i gotta go crack
some jokes and as soon as i said i'll do
it one time and see how it feels and it
felt great and it was what my house
needed my house needs for me to go out a
few nights a week
like my house really needs for me to go
out two three nights a week you have to
you know you cannot sit in that [ __ ]
house
you know
this whole thing that happened for two
years
people disappeared in themselves
during covert there was a time when when
i first got here i'm not gonna lie to
you
listen this week september 22nd is on
thursday
it's one year that i've been alive
like i've been alive for a year now
why do you remember the day
that was the first day i went to
acupuncture and i was petrified
when she was putting the needles on me i
was [ __ ] sweating bullets
i'm like i'm going to give her coverage
she's going to give me coverage
and then i took a one o'clock private
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu i had never done i
had lifted weights until then but i had
not done any jiu-jitsu and against what
i was thinking i'm like i got to go do
something let me just go
see what's going on up there and i went
in and i remember as i left i shook
coach's hand he just called me
at the sean and he i said i'll be back
and i go
this was tremendous today for more
reasons than one i couldn't even move
like on the floor i was so rusty from
jiu jitsu i was breathing heavy
but when i got up that day i go okay
and now i'm headed to the premiere of
the sopranos
so all that happened in one day and then
that was the same day all the same day
oh [ __ ] it was a wednesday and i [ __ ]
the car picked me up i was a little
nervous my friends came they we all took
a ride into the city
and
when i got to the [ __ ] premiere
i go what are you going to drop me off
to the driver he goes right there well
he dropped me off into 2000 people
it was on the street
and it was where you walk the green
carpet the red carpet whatever so when i
got there
these people jumped on me and i had
nowhere to go so i just started hugging
[ __ ] because what else are you
going to do i was hugging and i'm like
if i don't have covert now
i'm never going to get cold
i did the red carpet
and then i sat outside the theater i was
one of the last people to go in that
[ __ ] theater
like i did not want to go into beacon
theater with 2 000 people i i called you
from florida remember when there was a
restaurant the first time i saw a
restaurant with like a hundred people
that's right you went in that round
but after it was like a year at that
point
it was jarring like it was like what are
there supposed to be this many people in
here
you just got used like it's i think
that's why you're saying like it's good
to get out of the house
because like i think that's like working
from home is great
but at some point i think you start to
go a little bit crazy
just seeing just just like you go from
your bed to your chair and you're
wearing like a nice shirt with like
sweatpants or even like maybe just
shorts on and then you go to bed you got
the uber eats coming you go to netflix
and then you're like i don't know what
day it is today
i don't know i haven't seen anybody the
only person i see is zoom
it like it and especially like for you
for how what is it so 30 years
six nights a week you're out
at clubs and now like you're like you
know and not saying you're not having
fun but now you're going to softball
games
and
a restaurant like that's all like it
must have been
nice to get out of the house again i
think it was nice for everybody
i think it was nice for everybody a lot
of people forgot how to act with the
pandemic that's what we're finding out
now
but last night
it was like the pandemic never happened
you know and uh
it was just very interesting to see the
people out
the attitude of people i mean
it just blew me the [ __ ] away but
i gotta be honest here since you're on
the subject
i don't know if you watched bill maher
last sunday night bill moore had a great
i forget the guy's name now a podcast
guy i listened to his podcast he's been
on rogan
this guy went off on home on working
from home
and he had he made some great points
he's like we're in a [ __ ] volatile
society anyway for workers
and now you want people to work from
[ __ ] home
and people they do they have forgotten
how to live they forgot you know and
it's listen you walking into your you
don't even have to walk into a starbucks
but you walking into your favorite
coffee shop and getting a scone and a
cup of coffee in the morning before work
that's probably those are the things
that we need
that little hand in hand with people you
know it's great to walk into starbucks
and have a conversation with somebody
early in the morning hit you with a shot
of bad breath
but all those things add up yes you know
my life now for a long time i get up in
the morning i do what i got to do and
then i go to the gym
i get that over with and then but after
the [ __ ] gym if i don't go to jiu
jitsu i don't see anybody and even at
the gym you probably don't see many
people but that's why i like new york
because i'm like i don't really like
talking to a lot of people but
you're always like in new york if you're
walking you're always interacting like i
was when you were talking about the show
i think
if we get there early enough next time
it might be fun to just do like a block
around like a round just to like get the
f like because when you're walking
you're walking by people some homeless
guy is yelling it's just like i love
there's i love walking around new york
even and you used to talk about doing it
on smoking a joint i've never even done
that i just like doing it just to
like soak it in like a day like today
like like yesterday sunday it was
[ __ ] gorgeous yeah
you just take a bus and you go down to
like one of the parks
washington square
you know go to central park walk around
get a burger get a hot dog
i tell you man i forgot how much fun
that is just going for the city
you know you don't have to get [ __ ]
drunk you don't have to do quaaludes you
have to get your dick
just walk around
and you'll see people on the street
playing music you know you'll see a
bunch of [ __ ] and that's
that makes that's harmony man that
that's what
this was bad what happened most two
years and they're finding out the
effects of it now
with children and you know this guy last
week was talking about how bad working
from home is
how bad it is when guys go on
dating sites
because you forget the social
media of it it's just a scroll we're
forgetting all this [ __ ] you know i got
to be honest here
guys
kids do not know how to work
young kids today like when you go to a
restaurant
or go to an ice cream place and it's
just somebody young
there's no work ethic whatsoever
whatsoever there's no work ethic you
know so
we gotta get and then they you know
trump and biden have both stopped a lot
of immigration
so immigrants are the number one [ __ ]
workers we have you know [ __ ]
so it's like we're in a conundrum right
now i mean you know if guys don't know
how to go to a bar and pick up a chick
and it's it's it's not i'm not saying it
wrong
if you don't know how to communicate you
know i mean
i could never go on a dating site if i
was 28. it wouldn't work for me why
it just wouldn't work for me
like you need to be in like in front of
them and like i'd be in bed listen
see i'm embarrassed to do it that way i
don't like sending tapes
remember that the bling tape you know
but no i don't like sending tapes and
there's a reason why i like sending
tapes
because i miss that i miss that energy
from you
when i go into an audition even if i
suck at the audition we got to talk and
communicate so when i leave she goes
that wasn't a good audition but he's a
sweet guy
he's a nice guy he was prepared you know
it just wasn't fan you know what i'm
saying
you don't get that at all right when i
put an audition on tape i mean i'm
grateful that i put these audition on
tapes but
listen you just lost if your percent
whatever percentage you have of booking
an audition when i put it on paper i
just lost 15 points
i just lost 15 points because i didn't
go listen you know how many times i've
gone into an audition
and just been a nice person and [ __ ]
up the audition and she's turned off the
camera and said joey let's start this
from scratch i want you to get this then
they become your cheerleaders that's
cool and they talk to you when i [ __ ]
send a tape
you're not going to do that
i got lucky last week when i sent the
tape and they hit me twice dye your hair
and then do the audition standing up i
knew when they gave me the note i was in
they don't give me notes on [ __ ] self
tapes
you send the tape i sent the tape to
the play i never heard back
but again you know i had maybe a slight
chance of getting that play
with the audition on tape i lost it
same thing with women guys
if i and i got to be honest with you
if i swipe a phone
and i see a picture of a girl
and she's attractive she's like a six
right
i'm gonna go not really
and that's most guys no no i'm just
talking from the heart here that's most
guys we all want a tent right but guess
what
if i meet that girl and have a
conversation with her
maybe she's a [ __ ] sweetheart maybe
you know there's something else i like
about her childish quality maybe she
wears a ponytail and she reminds me of
my girlfriend in the first grade i don't
[ __ ] know
but you miss all that so then what do
you do when you swipe and you press do
they come over and [ __ ]
well when
when you look like me no but for some
people they do but no it's it's uh
but you're right because it sometimes
like you'll go and like you'll have like
a really cool message back and forth but
when you get to be in person it's
awkward because like
the nice the reason why i always did
online dating was because i was shy and
awkward and like you could think about
your response when they're right in
front of you and like you can't like
rewrite your message eight times some
weird like sometimes
the the problem with on like one of the
problems with online dating is
sometimes you'll talk for too long and
then you'll have nothing to talk about
like when you actually meet them like
it's it's not good
for
like actually getting to like in a
relationship getting him to know you
getting to love you
you didn't know you didn't miss out at
all but it's
i think people are
it's it i like it there are benefits to
working from home like i feel like i get
more done you do
yeah because when you go into the uh
the thing yeah the weird thing about the
office but and it's weird i get maybe a
little bit less done at the office but
you get certain things done more quickly
because you instead of sending an email
waiting for someone to get back to you
can just look over there and say hey jim
what am i supposed to do with this so
there are benefits to going to the
office
but
with
everything that's happened
people just don't want to and i i get it
i get it but it's
it's not going to be good
i don't know what what's going to happen
i like the social aspect of it yeah i
mean listen man i [ __ ] quit high
school like there's a 40-year
anniversary in october they keep bugging
me i'm like guys i'd be a hypocrite
i [ __ ] quit high school you know like
i [ __ ] uh i don't even know what
we're talking about you said you said
it's been 40 years you like the social
aspect of going into work
i i like
i
i didn't do good in school i had good
grades but i like going to school to
talk
to talk to teachers and see my friend
it's like my daughter i asked her a
month ago you ready to go to school
she's like [ __ ] yeah that's her social
life it's studio 54 to them you know
it's 350 for them so
and looks like my agent my asian work
from home
my agent new york matt great guy
and i was talking to him about it and he
made it a little garage he took his
garage and made an office and
you know it's great and he [ __ ]
works like you know eight to ten and
then he takes a walk for 40 minutes and
then he comes back and he does another
two hours you have to as long as you
have a schedule
and you adhere to that schedule like you
only want to sit down two hours
after two hours
it's the law of diminishing returns get
up take a walk i'd rather you take a
break that's why they give you a break
at a regular job 15 minutes you smoke a
cigarette we take a half-hour break
but they track you now like they can
track if your mouse like if you're right
so you have to get a computer thing and
put a weight on your mouse oh yeah
people are doing something i know a
check that does it she's
she [ __ ] puts the mouse puts like a
weight on it or something you buy an app
and it
yeah and it makes it move and she leaves
all day
she [ __ ] leaves to get 800 messages
where are you oh my you know
i seen her in the daytime she's a mom
she's one of the moms we hang out with
but i always liked the social listen man
the pandemic [ __ ] me up and i got to
be honest with you
there's still
people
in the house
oh yeah
there's still
people in the house i don't know if you
guys knew this this weekend was a big
weed expo in jersey
yeah and cheech was there chung oh okay
chunk showed and the guy chung's guy
called me last week hey he's going if
you want to go and i'm like and i go bro
that was the quickest 360. during the
pandemic i think for a year chong didn't
leave his bedroom
i remember you telling me about that
people come over and leave food in his
bedroom like there's one assistant he
wouldn't even leave the bedroom he had a
desk in there and a bathroom in there
and he didn't leave
the bedroom
and then he got better and better you
know he was scared he's 70 [ __ ] years
old i don't blame him so these guys
stayed in and i talked and the guy
called the other day man i want to let
you know he's coming and i'm like that
was quick because he was in the [ __ ]
closet he goes he just snapped one day
he couldn't take it no more
he just snapped
and that's what happened you can't
listen man you can't sit in this [ __ ]
house all the time you can't and i've
learned that
i'm not a house person i'm not a house
mouse
at all you know i like going out i like
talking to people
i like going to the gym you know jiu
jitsu i went to jiu jitsu because i was
lonely
right and i wanted to meet people in the
area
guys my age you know whatever and this
worked i went up there more for a social
than for exercising benefits and i fell
in love with the place
and there's days i have nothing going on
but i'll make sure to go to jiu jitsu so
i get my social
but how like just bringing it back to
last night
because i think there's probably a
difference between like the social you
get jiu-jitsu and the social you get
doing up like how do like how does is
that part of
you you might not need to do it every
night anymore but you do need to do it
every couple of weeks just i need to do
it once a week for my health for my you
know why because you go out and you
watch other comics like right now i'm
not looking to [ __ ]
sell out an arena right that's ship sale
i just want to do comedy and be happy
and make a little money and see my
friends this is what this is for
you know i get my friends to come to the
shows like my nephews came last night i
loved that they were there you know next
time my nieces will come my other
nephew's coming from ruth chris he's
gonna bring some steaks
next time i was gonna stop and get uh
pastrami from the pickled herring last
night but i'm like it's our first show i
don't want to say it i don't want to
stink up that
uv
with pastrami and
whatever
but
um
now the difference in my social with
comedy and whatever i mean
with jiu-jitsu i'm a fat [ __ ]
i'm in the third row with my gear all
[ __ ] twisted and i'm breathing heavy
and i'm sweating and my hair's all
[ __ ] up
at when i go do comedy you know
i don't know it's more for me i don't
know
like i really like the people i saw last
night in the audience like i really
liked those people last night they were
they were [ __ ] tremendous and like
just even
when like one of the first things you
said when you got into the car you
looked at your whoop and you're like i
burned 800 calories
and
something that i think people might not
understand like if you're watching
you think joe like they might think like
you're like the crazy like while like
really
all the time and you're really like most
of the time you're kind of subdued and
like really but to see you like
go off on stage it's just it's fun like
it just as your friend
it's fun
to see you do that like it was just like
like like i like when you make yourself
laugh on stage
is the best i ever the audience loves it
but like even
because you like you have a few
different laughs but you have one where
it catches you by surprise where you
where you said something you've never
said before
and it catches him by surprise and the
audience it just it's
it's fun to see like people have fun
like you know it's really fun to see
people have fun and it's really good
when you're the captain kirk of their
fun yeah like you take them to where
you know it's a great feeling and
you could do a thousand things you could
get your dick something nice
nothing matches being on stage
listen man
this is weird thing to say and i know
lee's going to relate to this and he's
going to go go [ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
but even when you're bombing
it's a little fun sometimes
because at first it hurts like your
first three years in comedy when you
bomb and your face gets red and
it hurts but after a while you have to
look at bombing like
this is necessary
for me to strive
i got a bomb
i got a bomb good for me to go home and
get pissed off and go [ __ ] you know
people need to get smacked in the face
there's some people that don't react
well like you see them in a fight
they'll go into the first round in a ufc
fight and they get beat up and thrown
down then they come out the second round
they start smacking [ __ ] and
throwing them out of the cage because
some people need to get smacked three
times
to get them [ __ ] going so
for me like after i came like you know
in the beginning when you're doing
comedy first two years it's like
[ __ ] having a band
and your first night you know first
night
[ __ ]
the cymbal breaks
the string breaks on the guitar you know
everything
it hurts that that's like a lot that's
trauma for some people yeah i've had
some bombings okay that have been
traumatic
it's like coming too fast you know it's
like [ __ ] your favorite chick and
coming in a minute but at least you
still come when that happens when you
put your bomb nothing nothing could
happen but you bomb when you come you
bomb
but
bombing is the first three years
especially when you get cocky and you
invite your employees
yeah come on down i'm going to kill it
tonight also you go up there and it's
[ __ ]
and you employ the next day they're like
that was very interesting and you're
like
oh
should i shoot myself now or in an hour
yeah and that sucks when you have to
face people again the next day after you
bombed
you know that's why i could never be on
a [ __ ] [ __ ] shoot uh
cruise ship oh can you imagine bombing
that yeah you breakfast with these
people the next day and they're looking
at you oh it was a very interesting set
last night oh you're very good and you
know you bumped and i was like that's
why when you said like right at the
beginning of this that oh i wasn't
nervous last before the show i was
[ __ ] i i
for pretty much the whole day
was like ready to like just explode
my well yeah dude first okay for i don't
want to let you
the show or the audience down and then i
like you said like you haven't when you
haven't done it in a while i just
started it up i didn't plan on like
when i came last time when we went to uh
uncle vinnie's you just sent me up and i
hadn't done it and now i'm do i've just
started a few open mics
and
like to just go up there and not really
know what's gonna happen
and i like i it made me think of like
the first time i did a club with you was
at cap city in austin and i was like two
months into stand-up danny brown was in
the back it was a i had just done the
fourth wall a few times which is eight
comics in a strip mall and then we're at
a sold out
cap city which is like you as a comedy
fan i've heard about it
and i get off i did three minutes it
went
fine for two months in and i stood up
against this back wall and my legs shook
because of the adrenaline and now i
called eric our buddy on the way to to
jersey a couple days ago he's like dude
you're on
like you and joey are on broadway like
joey's on broadway and i we're driving
in through times square and you do the
thing you love to [ __ ] with me a little
bit we're in the car you're like all
right we're gonna get there 808 you're
going on at 8 15. for cold and i'm just
sitting there and then like the people
the thing are like oh no jay's got the
dj's gonna go up first and i don't know
what's gonna happen
and i i in my head i'm just gonna go up
there
and have nothing to say
and just stare off into silence and like
run off
and look it went fine
but it was just yeah i i was losing my
[ __ ] in the car i just kept staring at
my phone
and like not even like really seeing the
words that were on the screen i just
kept going back and forth looking at
nothing
and oh my god but then you like e-r-e-u
matt fultron all you guys destroyed it
so
but yeah i
i was petrified i was gonna bomb
i was petrified
i was gonna bomb until i looked at my
material
and let me tell you something guys i
didn't do 30 minutes of material last
night that i had planned
i got off at 45 minutes because
i thought there was union
next time i'd do an hour i thought oh
they don't care
no he told me you have the whole night i
didn't know i thought we had to get off
at 10. yeah so i set the alarm for 10.
yeah i said i never set my [ __ ] i never
set my alarm but i have wanted to
because it's new york it's a theater i
don't know if they're union [ __ ] dog
after the [ __ ] union
yeah one minute late you get charged
like doubles
i gotta have the electrician unplug it
for 250
and then look at his assistant who gets
125
and then they got to plug it back in for
375 guys if you get that job
take it
take it 375 to plug in 250 every time
you plug that's it just plug it in 250
and the assistant that's watching him
gets a buck and a quarter to watch him
to witness it so
we're in the wrong [ __ ] uh
we're in the wrong [ __ ] business but
no i was
well yesterday i had a i had a room i
don't i'm comedy days listen i was a
little worried
let me tell you what my problems are
i don't like doing comedy with my family
right
right the day of
because they i got to be involved with
them
so yesterday that's the only thing that
had me a little
that they're around but then i went to
the softball games yeah and the [ __ ]
softball games were great yesterday yeah
lee got to experience
the [ __ ] softball games tell them
what they brought to the softball games
dawg oh what didn't they brought they
catered
a double header they came in we cater a
double [ __ ] header guys
they brought sandwiches from a place i'm
gonna tell you what the name of this
place is
[ __ ]
unbelievable these [ __ ] sandwiches
the name of this place is
it's a brooklyn place
but they [ __ ] opened up in staten
island the name of this place
is
royal crown bakery
1350
highland boulevard and staten island
guys
these [ __ ] sandwiches you know a
place is really italian when one of the
sections is
deaf menu is prosciutto and
and salami and but this was the one that
impressed me
they have a mortadella section so you
could get
mortadella look at this prosciutto
mozzarella prosciutto mozzarella roasted
peppers
prosciutto with mozzarella and grilled
eggplant prosciutto with mozzarella and
fried eggplant
mozzarella with sun-dried tomatoes
prosciutto with mozzarella and carbonada
presuto with mozzarella and broccoli rob
with mozzarella and arugula it don't
[ __ ] stop
mozzarella coca-cola super sad but
mortadella
with mozzarella
[ __ ] mortadella with mozzarella
roasted peppers
mortadella with american cheese ham has
a whole section grilled chicken they got
fried chicken sandwiches mozzarella and
roasted peppers this place is [ __ ]
sensational one of the moms catered for
us she got me and lee an italian [ __ ]
sandwich that was
sensational but tell them the clinker of
the [ __ ] day they brought chocolate
bread listen
i don't know who invented chocolate
bread it's like a it's like a
no
it's italian bread with chocolate chips
in that [ __ ] like syrup and
it's like sweet holy [ __ ] it's like uh
it's like almost like kind of like a
croissant but not really it's just like
soft in the middle and the thing was he
told me the night before he told me the
night before listen there's going to be
an italian sandwich there for you i we
get there like 11 30 and there's one
like the mom because she had to go i
don't know how far away that was but
like in the middle of the second game
she appeared i don't know like like an
angel with like three bags worth of food
and like you her husband and i
sat there and i don't think we talked we
didn't say one more look at the game
it just the sandwiches disappeared
oh my god i'm trying to think what the
[ __ ] cheese is on this thing
it was delicious
roasted peppers i mean it was [ __ ]
out of this mine and this is and we
didn't even do it see because you're all
you're about speed and and convenience
but they
individually packed little uh like
containers of the balsamic vinaigrette
and i took that i poured it and you were
like this is already by the time the
balsamic got there you didn't you didn't
have time for it no how good was it oh
because it just soaked up into the bread
but the bread was thick enough that it
didn't make it soggy it just kind of
absorbent oh i'm telling you this was
and they and they didn't put any
vegetables on it that's how you it was
cheese
smoked tomatoes go to subway [ __ ] if
you want that [ __ ] there was no lettuce
no tomato no vinegar oil no [ __ ]
mike's way whatever the [ __ ] you know go
[ __ ] yourself this was plain i mean it
was
yeah [ __ ] you with mike's way with the
with the vinegar and [ __ ]
but that was the softball game we had a
double header we sat there we got suntan
and her team is [ __ ] like
like they would i think one score was 17
to two
it almost wasn't fair like i think mercy
walked five times
she like like they just wouldn't throw
away
mercy they walked it
they kept walking and some other girl
hit a blast they won both games 17 yeah
all their innings they would score five
runs and they were [ __ ] come the
defense was tremendous and the coach
didn't he was yelling at them like they
were losing
but they need that [ __ ] it's it's a
different i'm happy
you got to experience
a saturday with me here like oh yeah and
i love how when you mess with the girls
because they're like eight nine years
old and you're like
ava you're a savage and she just looks
like you like what am i supposed to say
to this
and i show them knives i bring the girls
knives and they go nuts
i wasn't gonna say that part of that i
didn't know i don't know if that was out
yeah you took it out and one girl was
like i don't think you're supposed to
have that
like don't worry about it i take out
this big knife and i go girls this is
your good luck charm let's go out there
let's [ __ ] these [ __ ] up like
yeah
and then like everyone's paying the kids
for a home run it felt like it was like
jersey like every home run the kids got
a 20 bill
and then like they got what didn't since
they won didn't they get carvel or
something yeah they went and got sundays
there's across from carvalho this place
is [ __ ] tremendous and then little
joey came and i give him 20 a week oh my
god everybody these little kids get 20
bucks from me a week if he plays
football i give him a 20. if he throw he
he's he plays flag football but he
tackles [ __ ] because he's
little joey's my dog so i always said
how many flags you got i got i got eight
how many tackles three okay he scored a
touchdown so for every touchdown i give
him a 20.
if he gets four flags five flags i give
him ten if he gets ten flags i give him
20.
and that's the deal we have
and every time he sees me just goes in
my pocket give it to me give it to me
give it to me uncle joe he came up she
said money money
it's a different world man you know and
uh i'm happy you got to see it i know
michael has seen it like
you know soccer games saturday oh do you
have your first soccer game yeah it's uh
guys you know you think about it
like i never guys
listen
i never thought i would watch girl
softball
it's just not something that uncle joey
would do in fact when i went to my
father-in-law's he was watching girls
football and i said something to my wife
what's wrong with him
watching girl softball in the afternoon
and now i [ __ ] live for i mean i
don't watch it on tv yeah i was gonna
say you know no no you have a family you
have a daughter playing there it's not
like yeah you're not watching like
on espn too
but it's like they like you always hear
about like work-life balance like you
you have work-life balance now i didn't
have it before guys i had no balance i
had no balance in my life at all and i
didn't know what balance was we don't
get raised to have balance
we get raised to [ __ ] succeed we get
raised to make it happen
you know so
i don't [ __ ] understand that whole
thing you know we're going for it but i
think it uh
it like i think it's
doing good things for you because there
were some things last night
that like
i think old joey might have got a little
bit of my got a little bit upset about
like just like you know like with the
traffic i just ima and you were like
calm like you're like people
were
walking next to the car this guy was
walking next to the car listening to
your podcast
he just looked over he just turned to
the side he's like that's oh there's
joey
yeah he looked at me i had the window
open at the light he looked at me and he
goes
i'm listening to you as we speak i go
come over we started talking he lived in
west new york and [ __ ]
yes listen guys you gotta you know
i don't know i uh i [ __ ] up you know i
[ __ ] up during the pandemic and i'm
sorry i did i was a little too scared
but i missed
being social i'm a social type dude even
you know
three four people i love all that [ __ ]
watching football with guys you know
so this was rough for a lot of people
but i'm happy
that
people [ __ ] uh
are telling everybody go [ __ ] themselves
that's it enough of this [ __ ]
you know and now they're pushing the
[ __ ] you know they're pushing
vaccines like a [ __ ] again you
know what relax nobody's dying what are
you doing you know
people are starting to get that bearings
back and i'm [ __ ] happy this mess
with a lot of people
and last night
like that said i'm not even thinking
about it no more like that's it it's
nothing to think about you know they
keep pushing it but we just say [ __ ] you
i'm not doing it
i mean nobody even the [ __ ] because
the last couple times i went into the
city cab drivers and uber people had
masked
they don't even have the mask on no more
so
it's over it's time to [ __ ] get your
mental together and get back out there
and do what you were doing before this
[ __ ] [ __ ] started speaking of mental
now
for a word from better help
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
this podcast is sponsored by better help
guys do you ever fixate on a problem so
long that you don't know how to take the
time to find a solution
it can be tough to train your brain to
stay and problem solving mode when faced
with a challenge in life but when you
learn how to find your way out there's
no better feeling a therapist can help
you accomplish
become a better problem solver make it
easy to accomplish your goals listen
dana helped me out a lot i'm having a
a lot easier time now with my anxiety i
have little coping exercises so do me a
favor contact better help
they're going to make you right better
help is an online therapy that offers
video phone and chat sessions you can
choose not to see anyone if you want but
it's much more affordable and in-person
therapy and you'll probably get a
therapist within 48 hours so do me a
favor when you want to be a better
problem sob and take care of yourself
visit
betterhelp.com
diaz again
that's betterhelp.com diaz i'm going to
get you 10 off your first month who does
that for you nobody it's a monday
morning i woke up in a good mood so do
me a favor go to betterhelp.com
preston code diaz and i'll give you a 10
off your first month all right we're
back you bad [ __ ] don't forget
the
if you're having some problems at home
or you know you're struggling with focus
or whatever better help or take you to
the next level how do i know because
they took me to the next [ __ ] level
so what else is going on in your [ __ ]
world [ __ ]
i'm just doing i'm doing really good i'm
trying i'm happy that football is back
i'm just uh
but i i really am enjoying
doing stand-up it was i can't believe
how you dove back into it you came you
did the jersey show and also he's
talking to me i'm going on open mic in
new hampshire i'm going to see this it
but it's
because i never said that like i didn't
like say i love i've always loved doing
stand-up but i just
couldn't see myself struggling at it for
like 10 years it just seemed when you
think about that
it's it's a lot to put on like at least
for me i overthink everything i'm like
oh 10 years it's going to be too much
but then just doing it with you in
jersey
it just showed me how much because i
don't really have fun like that like i
don't know i'm a quiet person but
there's just something about being on
stage
that like i feel confident in a way that
i like i don't usually feel and i could
like talk to people i don't i don't know
what it is but it's just like i've
already made a couple friends in boston
and i'm doing them
at like bars
like worcester
has like there's this one bar with like
animal heads on the wall it smells like
feet it's been there since like the 60s
i went to one bar where my because my
girlfriend grew up in that area she's
like people die there
like they stab one bar has an open mic
and they had to change names because
they got someone got stabbed there like
two two months ago so they just have to
change names in the last year
but it's it's fun it's fun to
to just you know
get out and do and do stuff i'm having a
lot of fun
listen those ten years that you talk
about and people worry about for
anything
it's called an apprenticeship
okay
and no matter what you do
they're gonna take years off you know no
matter what you do if you play the piano
you play the guitar if you draw whatever
the [ __ ] you do they're going to take
years off you you know it's going to
cost you somewhere along the line
but while you're doing it you don't look
at it that way
so if you're at home and you're thinking
about doing stand-up or
joining a band or whatever
don't
don't worry about that because when
you're in it you're in it
you're not little when you see [ __ ]
matt fultron last night
matt fultron has been working hard for
15 [ __ ] years
he's not thinking about it
he's a [ __ ] working comic but in the
back of your mind you know that that day
could come at any minute that that
somebody could see you you could do a
[ __ ] video because you don't know
what it's going to be guys
you don't know what it's going to be
until you [ __ ] try it you might book
a movie with [ __ ]
all the movie stars and the movie tanks
and nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are
but then you might just do a [ __ ]
video of you singing a song and
everybody knows who you are you're never
going to know what's going to take you
to the next level until you do it but if
you don't do anything you're not going
to get to that next level anyway so do
it all
i was talking to jimmy the other day and
jimmy was going you know 30 years in the
business you can't figure [ __ ] out he
goes i do all these podcasts
nothing works nobody ever says to me hey
good podcast
he does god freeze podcast
godfrey put a clip up and got a million
hits
good for him and guess what african
americans are going to jimmy florentine
so do you understand he did a bunch of
white [ __ ] podcasts nothing happened
from rock music
ozzy black sabbath
ozzie's boneyard he does one he does
what's his name
god freeze podcast
and
you know he said the right things on it
the timing was right
but you don't plan that you know that's
why nothing burns me up i saw some
[ __ ] jerk-off comics from new york
about a year ago making statements about
you i went on the rogan podcast nothing
really happened for me
what do you think is going to happen
he's going to knock on your door the
next day and go hey we saw you on rogan
yesterday let's open the floodgates it's
not like that
you might have to do rogan four times
before something happens
but if you're depending on rogan
to blow your career up
then you you're wrong
you it's it's going on rogan and what
work you put in after rogan
it's not the tonight show that gets you
to the next level is what you're gonna
do afterwards right you know uh
but even like even for me though
because that's so far away like me
making it and stand up
i just and i know people are gonna be
like oh you're 34 years
to me i'm realizing that i'm
getting older
and even though i'm still young
i don't want to look back in 20 years
like you said that two years it went by
quickly i don't want to look back in 20
years and feel like i didn't give it a
shot so even if i
because in like reality i'll probably
never be a a headline i'd like to be
there
no but it's just fun you cannot
put a [ __ ] ceiling over your career
right you're gonna do comedy you're
gonna play the flute you're gonna do
whatever the [ __ ] you're gonna do
for your happiness yeah okay and it
becomes a hobby and it becomes whatever
you wanted to become you have a day job
so but never guys listen to me
i used to be lee i used to sound like
lee
okay
life had to kick me in the [ __ ] teeth
to show me that anything is possible in
this world
guys take it from me
i was a felon i had nothing going on i'm
not good looking i lost my daughter
nobody wanted to lurk with me but i
stuck with comedy
nobody wanted to hang out with me no the
line is nobody wanted to lurk with me
that's a shirt yeah
do you think now at night i sit there
and and now i have a positive outlook
more than i had before
because when i did comedy in the
beginning yeah it was to get out of
being a criminal and become a a human
being but i didn't know
i was going to get to hang with joe
rogan and dave chappelle and do comedy
with chappelle in 2001
and just a thousand things like guys i
never saw a movie
if you think i was telling my friends
i'm gonna be in a movie but
to go back to a podcast we did two weeks
ago
we were talking about debt
and i'm like listen this is what i'm
gonna do
i'm gonna be fair about this i'm gonna
go into debt if i make it i pay the
bills
if i don't you're in debt
[Music]
but i'm gonna make it because i need to
pay these bills i don't want to live my
life as a [ __ ] deadbeat right so guys
when you you know a kid was here joey
joey came over the other day we're
watching college football
little joey the reason why
10 bucks is because he didn't want to
play he goes there and he's like i don't
want to play he's the toughest kid in
the team he's [ __ ] a great athlete
and he's a little scared he didn't like
it so i would talk to him every week
joey your father's gonna [ __ ] shoot
you
he's a little scared your dad's going to
shoot you you better go in that game but
let me tell you what happened he was
here two fridays ago because they come
over on fridays the girls hang out and
then joey hangs out with me down here
and my wife hangs out with joey's mom
upstairs we're watching college football
and the guy scored and i go joey you run
like that
and he looked at me like
and i go joey that could be you
that could be you in 20 years and i'm
not lying to anybody
i'm not lying that could be you joey
it hit him so hard he just passed out
it was like giving him nyquil he looked
at me like it could be me boom he just
passed out from the [ __ ] thought of
that yeah people really don't like
people go you're gonna be a rock star
i'm gonna do this but in there at night
they're crying they're like i don't want
to do it
i don't wanna just wear spandex pants
you know whatever the [ __ ] it is
i don't wanna do it i don't wanna do it
but
don't ever [ __ ] nudge yourself out
because if your uncle joey did it
could you imagine what you could do
and i've been telling people this since
i've been doing a podcast
if i did this can you imagine what you
could do with a loving family no drugs
and people who care about your [ __ ] you
know
i did all this [ __ ] with nobody in my
corner yeah in 200 2000 i met my wife i
was nine years into comedy but those
rough years i did on my own you know
those were bus rides
bombing nobody talks to you
you know triple runs that that's not a
[ __ ] great career sleeping in your
car eating subway veggie and cheese
sandwiches
that's not a great career but it beat my
alternative which was prison
yeah that's a lot better than prison it
beat my alternative
listen man i got into comedy to get out
of this criminal world
and
if i could do something with stand-up
and stupid movies and auditions i can't
imagine what you guys could do
but and how much i know obviously when
you're broke it must not it's not fun no
but how much of that time was fun for
you doing those gigs and doing those
triple runs
was it fun in the moment
guys you watch mtv
and you see these bands you know and
you're like man i wish i could do that
be on a [ __ ] bus
with zach wilde you know and yeah but
then now you're in you're in the micro
world you're not hanging out with zach
wilde and i'm not hanging out with dave
chappelle i'm not hanging out with joe
rogue and i'm not hanging out with bill
burrow dean
it's just me on a greyhound bus and it
reminds you of uh
water backed all live
when bon jovi's singing it and he's on
the video and he's on the bus and he's
looking around and you know you don't
know those words like when you listen to
his words and bob seeger
on the road the one song he's got you
know that's what like for me i didn't
care if i was alone i didn't care three
dollars in my pocket i didn't give a
[ __ ] that my walkman needed batteries
i was doing it even if i was a feature
act for 100 a night guess what
i'm in it
i'm in it and it
and guess what it was a lot of fun and
that's why i tell people i do it all
over again
because i never knew what i was walking
into
and how
how long would it take or how often
would you see yourself improve would be
like every six months oh [ __ ] i did like
every 90 days i'd see something that
would keep me alive for another 90.
really i would always go if this doesn't
change in 90 days i'm quitting this [ __ ]
i'm done with this [ __ ] i go so cold why
am i doing this why am i working 400
hours a night they only give me 50 up
front and mail me a check no no no when
i first started with triple was 85 a
night oh and he gave you 50 up front and
35 he mailed you
a month later it's just a random number
how many of them how many 35 checks did
you get
well it's every night so if you have
six shows and he owes you 635 okay
so you got to check two weeks later and
[ __ ] like that but i didn't give a [ __ ]
because i knew what the alternative was
when you're in it you're not thinking
well it's i got six more years to be
good no because this lottery ticket
could cash today
yeah or it could never cash which is i
mean
it's if you put the work in and believe
in your heart and stay pure to yourself
you'll cash a portion of it
it's not going to be the 21 million you
wanted
you know
it could be 2100
right guess what
you did that
you did that
so when they pay me 2100 i'm really
worth 10 000 but i can't raise my hand
guess what i did this by cracking jokes
i did this by writing a song somebody
paid me money to write a [ __ ]
soundtrack
you know nobody knows my name
can you imagine being a ghost rider
you're sitting there at home watching tv
and your commercial comes on for
cadillac and it's your thought it's your
jingle you just got 300 000 in the
[ __ ] mail for it because that's what
you get from commercial music when you
do music for commercials that's when you
get rich quick yeah yeah and every time
they keep playing
[Music]
so
just being in the game
listen
if you think i'm any good at jiu jitsu
you got rocks in your head
but i keep going
because i know it'll change for me i
know eventually out the switch
is going to go off i saw i saw a picture
did you demote yourself
why did you do it why didn't i
i saw that i was like did he did he take
away his bluebell i took away my own
bluebell i didn't feel like a blue belt
it was a celebrity blue belt they gave
me an l.a no disrespect to alberto he
saw some of me i was working hard and
stuff but i didn't feel like a blue belt
and then i got the i understood what a
blue belt meant and i accepted it
but then i was like i would i was off
the mats for a year and a half
and if i sucked when i was on it three
times a week
how bad would i suck on it now so when i
joined gracie i started from scratch i
did a couple privates
and i when he when i went in he goes if
you want to put your blue balls on
you're more welcome i go not at all i
want to start this program from scratch
so i went in with one strike
wow
yeah
i didn't feel like a blue belt
so if you don't feel like a blue belt
how can i parade myself i'm barely a
white belt with two stripes that's how
good i am i got a scissor sweep i could
pass your guard
you know i know what a [ __ ] uh
delahiva is but i'm not good at
jiu-jitsu
so what do i do quit no you keep going
you make a plan with yourself i catch i
catch one core class and two
blue belt classes and i do the best i
can and i know eventually someday i'll
feel like a blue belt
and at least you're honest with yourself
yeah like you're not like you're not
jumping in there with the brown belts
now after being in la how can you do you
see how important it is to be honest
with yourself because you saw it
he sees the fight he saw it i don't have
to sell him on anything
i don't have to tell him anything he
used to tell me what he saw
you know the the you have to check
yourself you have to be honest with
yourself and go this isn't working
or i'm going to do this for six more
months and maybe do this and adjust this
but
you see it out there that people
and you're like why why are they still
here you feel for them
but again i can't take nothing away from
them because anything can happen
at any time
in my world it's always wednesday you
know what wednesday is on the mickey
mouse club
no
it's anything can happen today
in my world every morning i wake up and
it's anything can happen today
but that goes two ways you get hit by a
car
or you get your dick sucked you follow
me so we get up every morning it's a 50
50 chance but do you think
anything is possible if you're not
honest with yourself
i think you have to be honest with
yourself listen anything can happen
whether you're honest with yourself or
not honest with yourself
but can you maintain that level without
being honest with yourself
that's a weird thing if you see a lot of
the comedians i'm not mentioning no
names
but if you see a lot of comics right now
they got a little bit of an ego
that's what happens after and then you
become preachy on stage
and that's what happens to comics they
get that [ __ ] ego i don't want to
[ __ ] with that ego and you always you
relate comedy to
mma a lot and to me it seems like how
sometimes
you'll see a fighter lose
and then they actually but then they
fix whatever like made them lose that
fight and then they go and become champ
like i think what happened to kamaru it
happened a bunch of people and i think
that's what happens
because you'll also point to fighters
who will continually lose
making the same mistake
so i think i think that has to be the
same in stand-up
where
if you don't look at okay i'm not gonna
crowd work or i don't i can't follow
this kind of person
i don't know if you will get better
i mean you tell me i i don't know
anything i'm two years you have to
listen metal sharpens metal
so
i mean if you want to go down to
i don't know i don't even know how to
describe this if you know if you want to
go down if you want to be the big fish
in a small ocean
or if you want to be a little fish in a
big ocean
and i always wanted to be a little fish
in a big ocean because i have a chance
to learn
when you're a big fish in a little ocean
like if like for me to
right now for me to pack up my bags and
go to like
denver
okay
and go there with ego
and smash the open micros and
bump them
you know bump him go i'm going up next
looking gangster try to do that
it doesn't uh
i don't like that i don't see the beauty
in that
i never wanted to be that guy that came
home and said you know i was at the
comedy store and that's all i'm talking
about you know
and you know come on guy
so
you [ __ ] uh
do the best you can
you stay honest with yourself you know
you look at other people and you go wow
he's doing something that i'm not doing
you know i'm doing he's doing something
i'm not doing
what is he doing to get ahead that i
need to do and you'll see and you
jump on
life is a beautiful thing guys
you know
you could either [ __ ] sit on the
bench or going and playing the game in
life it's up to you
and it's just
fun it's fun to like when you try
something like as scared as i was
yesterday
like oh and i'm not gonna name any names
but we were doing a
show in vegas once and there was a new
comic
who
had just been doing it and you asked him
if he wanted to go on
and he he didn't and i get that i get
being scared to go on in front of like i
don't know what that was a thousand
people
and but i think that might have been
like the last time he did stand up yeah
he lost
he lost
and you have to
you know when somebody gives you an
opportunity you got to jump on it
you know i mean listen
if [ __ ]
dungeon rose just called me today
and they said hey
you know uh we want your band to open
for us i gotta evaluate the band to see
if i'm ready for that
are we ready for this you don't know
where you're getting yourself into you
know
this is hanging out with these [ __ ]
savages this is a different
music experience
so you have to be where you're
comfortable you know you don't ever want
to be somewhere
like if i was doing comedy in 2000 and
somebody called me to go on a major tour
i was a little stupid i would have done
it [ __ ] myself up and then never
worked again
thank god nobody called me on a major
league tour they called me later on when
i could do it you know
right
but succeeding in anything you got to
stick it out we've discussed this for
[ __ ] 12 years about
just keep showing up
and good things are going to happen
eventually eventually
what's that stupid [ __ ] cliche
expression no good deed goes unpunished
i'm telling you guys that that
i'm living proof
put your [ __ ] work effort into it you
have to make a few sacrifices you know
just a few sacrifices
things that you really want to do that
you can't do no more because this is
what you want to do and this is what
needs to be done but it's also
that's why
whether i don't know if you want to call
it a hobby for me or not but it's
something
that i don't really see what i'm doing
for stand up at least not yet as a
sacrifice and i'm sure eventually if i
wanted to like take it to the next level
it might feel like a sacrifice
but for right now
it's just it's something that's only
been fun you like the you like the
boston red sox right yes you like the
new england patriots of course okay so
when you [ __ ] put your sneakers on
and you leave your children
your wife
athena i leave mercy and my wife
to [ __ ]
go do whatever
that's huge guys there's people who will
never do that
you know how hard it is for some people
to put their sneak you know how hard it
is for me to put my sneakers on at 7 30
for the [ __ ] year i was here wasn't
gonna happen
it wasn't gonna happen
but once you're willing to make the
sacrifice just that alone
i mean if you live by yourself and
you're a jamoak in a basement and you
have a pet lizard it don't matter what
i'm saying
let lizard's fun hang out yeah we don't
even eat leaves that meat no more so
that's good
but
you know everything's a [ __ ]
sacrifice when you have to go out at
night you like the red sox
you know if it's a sunday night new
england's playing late game you have to
go do a spot you know these are all
sacrifices guys i have to walk away from
my daughter at dinner
it's all [ __ ] sacrifices and you know
what man i think they always get
rewarded i think everything gets
rewarded i told you guys once that the
universe takes care of you
but they have to see that you're making
a [ __ ] effort and that's
that's the most important [ __ ] thing
and that's it for a beautiful [ __ ]
monday morning
in september we're not [ __ ] around
when i keep you here all day it's monday
morning we just wanna put a good word
into your ears so the rest of the week
is [ __ ] beautiful i'm doing the sony
theater again
october eight do not pay over 40 dollars
for tickets
lee will be here with me again and uh
the show's gonna get bigger and better i
i see it coming i want to thank the sony
hall
for even thinking of me and uh it all
worked out and
my [ __ ] the the
biggest star of the night uh saturday
night was laughing gas
i want to thank scott and joe peppa and
the crew from laughing gas
they came they gave away t-shirts they
gave away bags they gave away bags of
reefer
just a tremendous i'm very proud to be
uh
together with laughing gas they really
did a great job and that's it and that's
that thank you brother thank you thank
you mike for coming last night it was a
lot of [ __ ] fun and it's monday
morning [ __ ] you own this [ __ ]
i'll see you [ __ ] wednesday
morning dip
top magoo
now for a word for my [ __ ] sponsor
jack
all right you bad [ __ ] i want
to thank uh lisato and thank mike
but most importantly i wanna thank you
savages for always having my back
this week's podcast today's podcast is
brought to you by
better help
guys
you have problems have you having a hard
time solving problems you don't know
what you're feeling it could be tough
for your brain to stay in
problem-solving mode when faced with a
challenge in life but when you learn how
to find how to work with that challenge
there's no better feeling and a
therapist can help you
become a better problem solver
do me a favor go to betterhelp.com
why is therapy important i'll tell you
why because you can't solve all the
things on your own
we got so much information growing at us
we don't know whether we're coming or
going get your help
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and chat therapy
sessions you could choose not to see
anybody on camera or you could see
somebody on camera it's a lot more
affordable than in-person therapy you
want to become a better problem solver
do me a favor therapy can help you visit
betterhelp.com right now pression
diaz
code diaz i'm going to get you 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp.com
diaz the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings you bad [ __ ] it's
time to make some [ __ ] cash it's
football season it's baseball's playoff
season
i mean college football what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you waiting on to
download the draftking sports book app
they're an official sports betting part
of the nfl the ufc
they got big plays and even bigger wins
and they got an incredible offer you
ready five dollars on any nfl team wins
your 200 feet bets did you hear what i
said
five dollars on any nfl team
wins you 200 and free bets
but there's more they stepped up the
same game paul a
so every leg you add you can boost your
winnings by a hundred percent with big
payouts
why bet football anywhere else
go down the same game paulie
per game day all season long that's why
draftkings are the kin so download the
draftking sportsbook app today use promo
code joey j-o-e-y and get 203 bets
that's code joey only at draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner the nfl minimum age and
eligibility restrictions applied see
show notes for details let's win some
cash [ __ ] draftkings
the best i want to thank draftkings i
want to thank better help i want to
thank all of you [ __ ] and i'll
see you wednesday
tip top magoo
have a great day
[Music]
[Music]
you